صراحه ما تخيل ابدا بيوم من الايام اني
ممكن يعني لو تعلم لغه التركيه راح يساعد
العدد الكبير من الناس هذا خصوصا انه بعد
هذه اول مره ازور فيها تركيا يعني الحمد
لله اللي قدرت اساعد لو شيء بسيط لغتي
المتوفر عندي
صحيح الحمد لله يعني التواصل كان ممتاز
جدا قدرت قدرنا يعني نحل امور كثيره نفهم
ايش احتياجاتهم ايش المشاكل اللي عندهم
كيف ممكن نقدر نساعدهم كذلك يعني بتنقلات
الفريق كلها الحمد لله كانت عن طريق
ترجمتي الى اللغه التركيه
الصدق سابقا يعني انا قريب رحت مثلا
العمره تفاهمت مع اتراك يعني واحده كانت
ضايعه نفس الشيء مره واحده بالمطار بس
كممارسه لا هذه اول مره امارسها فعليا
خصوصا انا ما عندي ما اعرف ناس اتراك حولي
ما حد يعرف اللغه التركيه او يتقنها صح
فكانت هذه اول ممارسه فعليه للغه طبعا زي
ما ذكرت لكم مسبقا انت مع الهلال الاحمر
فدورنا يعني مساعدات صحيه زي ما انت عارف
الناس الحين طالعين من بيوتهم فما عندهم
في ناس كثير ما يكون عندهم ادويتهم او
تجلسوا بناموا باماكن بارده فيكون حنا
عندنا حل مبدئي المشاكلهم اللي موجوده
الان نقدر باللي نقدر عليه نساعدهم